degrees uh you play Ashton's best friend
in this but I feel like everyone wants
to be your best friend I
you go so everybody
you also seems so supportive also just
like a good time you know
be best friends
I love that speaking of fun you had a
little surprise on Jimmy Kimmel tonight
with the look back of your career and it
was a clip from E.T we dug up an
interview that you did when you were I
think 14 years old but you know what I
think would be really fascinating
30 years from now going to the movie
like the the video store and uh running
running the Man in the Moon LaserDisc
and uh
watching with my kids and having my kids
understand it what would you like to see
that video it was so sweet I just like a
blast from the past yeah like I feel
very tender about little little me you
know she had no idea knows ahead of her
bumps in the road but she got through it
I mean how surreal is it to be in that
exact space now where your kids can
watch your movies
amazing my children are so incredibly
supportive I was just talking to my son
and my daughter on the way here and
they're just like Mom you're so great
tonight and it's great to have adult
children and also I have a wonderful
little 10 year old too and
I'm just I'm very lucky very very lucky
to have nice kids we're so lucky that
we're gonna get an election sequel I
mean does this mean that we get to see
Tracy flick all grown and out in the
real world
I hope so wouldn't that be fun yeah I
think I want to check in with her and
see where she's been the last 20 years
there's going to be another sort of
election type thing inside that movie I
mean you would know right I might now I
might know too much and real quick it's
the Jennifer Coolidge Renaissance right
now you must be so excited to be on
myself about Jennifer Coolidge she
deserves every one of those flowers she
is receiving right now and she's just
one of those people who is so naturally
gifted and funny and that you can just
tell people love her because she gets up
there and everybody's like I love her
but she's just doing a lot of good work
in our business for so long that it's
really nice to see her getting this
incredible moment how will we see her
crown give her a crown she deserves one
I'm gonna give her a crown Jennifer
coolidge's royalty are we gonna see that
Queen in Legally Blonde three and how so
there there is no legally voluntary
without Jennifer Coolidge yeah I love it
[Music]